hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to let's play condemned
okay I accidentally went in this room
instead of that but I went through that
horrible ordeal and I totally haha did
not die a bunch trying to get that fire
axe but yeah I I got involved in that
and then I just got into everything a
good don't judge me
you didn't you just see anything I was
totally alive for the whole time
hey guys scared me link no damn but what
Wow
got you I saw that I am an officer of
the law you will obey and then I will
kill you
do not give me any reason to think that
you are threatening in any way because I
will probably murder your face anyway no
matter what you do you're probably gonna
die okay that lies that thing actually
coming is that actually uh-huh well good
thing they weren't in there I hope I'm
going to the right place I'm assuming
them walking in a single-file was sort
of an indication that I was supposed to
go that way just assuming oh I'm back up
here is where I started I'm not go there
away ah oh yo yo yo ho give me that a
machine-gun where these like for these
thugs getting you nope
you know I'm getting up rubbish rotten
too but give it that oh hell yeah 20
shots I'm like a bad ass of a cop on the
edge I'm still gonna indiscriminately
murder everybody I see but man I'm gonna
do it
hi if fps or shots I don't know I'm
gonna do it a lot very quickly spray
molten death into your eyeballs aw come
on oh my god but a woman
and if all guns to have in a strange
area why would it be what looks like an
old know that I don't know what Top Gun
I'm not very much in the gun so I don't
know what anything is I just assumed
that it would be like an Uzi or
something I'm gonna go back get it they
can't accept they can't take away my
love they can't stop the way I feel
about you my darling gun weapon mmm I
love you so much i caress your long
barrel you're so big and strong like
I've seen birdbath TV achievement well
good for me aren't I just the greatest
ever
hello no it's not okay I went the wrong
way up here no don't even think about
getting in my way chair you can't stop
me I'm a cop on the edge I don't know
what I'm gonna do next
what is this hi
what is this what's going on was I'm not
supposed to go that way huh probably not
let's see here
oh well where's the rail I'm gonna kill
someone I'm gonna kill them dead
ahh
cuz I couldn't have done that with my
bare hands I better not need another
crowbar swear I'm gonna be so upset I'm
gonna be angry even I'm gonna be
slightly ticked up enough go I let me up
the mill I've come on really
let's try get out of the way we're let
me if we let me go away your sir don't
think you didn't see Teddy that's great
I don't even know who she no fail
anybody else was haha
he came right at me OOP I said what oh
oh did that hurt
I'm sorry I'm a cop I don't care about
your pain or something like that I don't
know if that's what's supposed to happen
I see a piece of metal back there but
I'm alright
how did Rosa get up here away from
whoever kidnapped her and also these
guys with guns Shelbourne reading room
rare books this way hey Rosa I'm here to
save you oh hello oh no don't tell me
there's a dead body don't oh oh no oh no
what's he not dead
see I thought I saw boo oh that's a bird
ha ha ha okay that's good
sledgehammer please how do I open this
where do i sledge where do i hammer down
oh hello I see you that don't think I
don't see that up there how do I get up
there
how do I do that I'm supposed to have
the sledgehammer for a reason I'm
assuming aa ladder oh yeah
get over here oh come on how's that not
what it's supposed to be fine all right
oh wait no I'm I just an idiot no I'm
not but that one of that nope okay
fail failure hello Rose are my dear
there seems to be a problem obviously
I'm supposed to be able to get up there
somehow but I can't jump I'm unable to
jump my bones and muscles are too big
and heavy to jump
apparently what's going on here um let
me go back maybe I supposed to get that
such a Murphy something over here I
don't know I'm a big dumb cop what do I
know
I know I got a swing a sledgehammer III
lift things up and put them down I lift
things up and put them down
hey John
hi I this thing job and put them down I
think that's the way back down so ah
okay how do I get back there cuz
obviously there's a way either
I'm just the biggest idiot that ever was
when there is an obvious way than I'm
not saying what's wrong with me what is
wrong with me why can't I solve anything
I'm trying to look at this objectively
everybody out there watching but I just
cannot see it but noms both oppress
shout gun fledge hammer
what is the deal what is the deal
by they sports our topple like dominoes
until I can climb up them this ladder
just for decoration oh come on
Oh dinner right in front of it you're
not gonna do it never mind never mind
never mind just never mind I swear I was
standing right there I was spamming my
use key and didn't hello birdie can you
jump jump down thank you all
such a badass you okay taking a nap back
off you bastard come any closer and I'll
rip your head off
really okay it's me Thomas oh oh oh he
must have clobbered me in the back of
the head before taking off really call
you okay told oh there is these shadowy
things standing over you what look well
you're chasing shadows that jerk tried
to kill me I bit him good though right
on the hand uh-huh did you get any of
the blood sampled I saw some hit the
floor yes
Oh samples and transferred back to the
lab excellent but how did I lose track
of you I can patch in through this
computer and do a remote analysis how
are you using the computer if you were
unconscious
Oh spike why me from the central axis
DNA taken from the video station hideout
this is the guy this is our serial
killer X huh he killed a policeman Oh
killing all of the other guys on your
case list whoa
what did he want with you he wanted to
know what we knew about the torturer huh
you made me look it up on the net
the whole mo now that reduction torture
suicide de Thomas the torture is on your
case list and he's the only one whose
trail hasn't gone cold since we ran into
this serial killer access ex wants the
torturer to die okay he's hunting him
down oh that's so sad maybe we should
let him yes
this is Jennifer Alden reporting from
police headquarters in developments in
the case of the torturer serial killer
hole really gym teacher from the city's
juvenile rehabilitation program well
informed police of contact he had almost
eight years ago with a troubled youth
named Carl Anderson sir NC max directors
Gurley authorities are now asking the
public to inform police if they know of
Carl Anderson swearable oh boy do not
approach the suspect as he should be
considered armed and dangerous
guys sources within the police
department are telling me they are also
concerned because their informant can no
longer be located fun times
spokespersons have refused comment on
this latest development this is Jennifer
Albin reporting for news channel 5 a
general Anderson gym teacher tells the
cops on you and now the teacher can't be
found right okay Rosa we have to find
the school with this teacher work why
school and city district records are in
the basement okay follow me hopefully
this key will get us where we need to go
okay sounds good whatever you say lady
up can't move
we could have opened that at any time
yeah those bars I aren't exactly high
could have climbed up over it because
I'm so strong can I can I have my
submachine gun back please
thank you I would lie I like this gun I
like too loud oh yeah
move faster I'm a cop on the edge okay
yeah but nobody okay right up don't turn
around oh my oh don't think I don't have
my suspicions I don't trust anyone
especially the female characters that
seem like they're trying to help me just
like dead space I don't trust you not
one bit okay he's gonna let me go you
lock the door behind me
go to color your color your G you better
hurry up
oh you're following me now okay it's
okay be careful
i'ma come on edge you know what I'm
capable of
what the hell what the hell's that
Wow sounds like an animal is crawling
around up there hello huh uh I saw
something geez
Gayla jumpy here what job I'm a cop on
the edge you don't know who you're
messing with
why do we have to go down to the
basement it seems like a bad idea
looks like this is where the library
yeah got ya I think okay there should be
a stairwell that leads down to the
microfiche room right the microfiche I
love me some fish oh here we go
oh this how is looking back here huh
whoops not bad I guess I didn't follow
protocol hey could I just didn't feel
like it
oh hey lady I hope you feel safe while I
don't keep an eye on you at all yeah I
mean you slipped away you were kidnapped
when you were standing right next to me
so I don't know how safe you feel
helping few feet away oh my god
[ __ ] up huh oh come on
and then hurt yeah I did but not such a
bad ass yeah I'm fine
you're not gonna be able to up there
yeah busted my flashlight oh don't tell
me that I thought I saw something down
there on the door I'll be hearing it it
why don't you jump down I'll catch ya I
don't want to wait for Rosa lights
you're gonna go out our thing
ah
oh boy hey hey oh
ah Oh God
Thomas it's me snap out of it here take
my flashlight oh okay make your way
around to the doors on the other side
I'll let you in there okay don't take
too long
standing in the dark without my
flashlight makes me nervous no joke well
it makes me pop probably insane and
reliable to attack you so FRA good idea
ha that's right
back off I'm a cop on the edge ah shut
up
oh my poor guy 13 okie dokie I'm
actually all at a time thank you all so
much for watching click the annotations
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
video part thing bye bye